i hate merging code from different  developers  mergers are difficult and often create  bugs kind of like when you introduce  cats to each other so what do we do with  tasks that are dangerous and time  consuming  we do them more often that way we will  get feedback earlier and we will  automate them  this is the principle behind continuous  integration some people call it shift  left as you're moving tasks from the end  of the process to earlier in the process  if you are using cloud run you may have  built your software on google's servers  with cloud build  but you can also use cloud build to  script deployments and tests  if you trigger this process on code  commits you discover bugs earlier in the  project  much better than finding them right  before it's time to ship  your code modules and your developers  will be happier together  see the description below for examples  to get you started